c'est l'heure du second débat de sens
public direction l'Argentine à 5 jours
de l'investiture officielle de ravier
Miley le nouveau président populiste qui
fait revenir l'extrême droite au pouvoir
après des décennies de péronisme comment
l'a-t-il emporté pourra-t-il appliquer
son programme économique qui sont ses
alliés et ses ennemis au sein de la
société argentine avant de répondre à
ces questions son portrait signé Flora
sauvage antisystème libertarien et
climatoceptique le N président
argentinavier M a promis lors de sa
campagne équipé d'une tronçonneuse de
tailler drastiquement dans les dépenses
publiques et de lutter contre la caste
politique qui paralyse à ses yeux le
pays dans une vidéo publié sur TikTok il
met en scène la taille dans les
ministères Ministerio de
culturauera Ministerio de ambiente y
desarro
sostenibleuera Ministerio de las mujeres
y soutient la libéralisation des ventes
d'armes etère que traic d'organ devrait
être un marché comme les autres ravier
my veut abroger la loi sur l'IVG en
récoltant plus de 55 % des voix à
l'élection présidentielle cet économiste
de 53 ans a réussi à séduire une
majorité d'argentin touché de plein
fouet par une inflation galopante 4
argentins sur 10 vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec un taux d'inflation qui
dépasse les 140 % par mois il est clair
que il y a eu une volonté d'exprimer un
changement par rapport
au gouvernement sortant et de manière
plus générale à la classe politique qu'à
dénoncé jaier my face à un endettement
colossale et une monnaie qui dévisse
ravier my a fait campagne sur la
dollisation de l'économie et la
suppression de la Banque centrale la
vraie question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce qu'il sera en mesure
d'incarner sur la durée ce gouvernement
alors qu'il n'a pas de majorité au
Parlement de semaines après son élection
ravier Miley sera investi dimanche à la
tête de l'Argentine en en attendant il
peaufine la composition de son
gouvernement et a nommeré rodolpo Barra
un ancien ministre au passé nazi comme
procureur général auprès du
Trésor à quoi va ressembler l'Argentine
de ravier my pourra-t-il tenir ses
promesses on en débat avec maricelle
Rodriguez Blanco bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes maîtresse de conférence en
sociologie à l'Institut catholique de
Paris Angeline Montoya bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste au Monde
en charge de l'Amérique latine
Christophe Ventura bonsoir et bienvenue
directeur de recherche àiris en charge
programme Amérique latine Caraïb et
Laetiticia crupa est resté à mes côtés
et je rappelle Laeticia que vous avez
publié la tentation du clown aux
éditions bchet Chastel dans lequel vous
analysiez les les trajectoires de ces
élus populistes candidats horors système
qui sont souvent issus de la société du
spectacle ça correspond mot pour mot à
Ravière
Miley maricelle Rodriguez Blanco est-ce
qu'il a déjà sorti la tronçonneuse là
c'était vraiment son principal argument
de campagne pour reprendre cette image
choc quelles ont été les premières
décisions d'e du futur président du
président élu on va dire ça comme ça
puisque il prête serrement dimanche euh
bah une des décisions qu'il a prise
qu'il avait annoncé et qu'il a
finalement prise c'est deeuer deux
voyages international donc un aux
États-Unis euh et un autre en Israël
qu'il a passe encore enfin qu'il voilà
qu'il avait promis en tout cas qu'il
allait effectuer et euh aussi il a déjà
commencé à privatiser un un média en
fait qu'un une chaîne des communication
euh et puis concernant les premières
mesures en matière de privatisation il
est ça ça annoncé on on attend en tout
cas à partir de la des premiers mois de
gouvernement on va voir un peu la
couleur de façon plus plus précise
concernant les mesures de privatisation
qu'il a qu'il a annoncé mais il y a pas
des raisons qu'il qu'il avance pas en
fait dans sur C ces plans là alors il y
a déjà eu Angé Montoya une sur la
question de la dollarisation de
l'économie là là il y a eu clairement un
une marche arrière on va dire de ravier
MCE qu' Mar marche arrière je ne sais
pas en tout cas pour l'instant on n
parle pas il a toujours dit de toute de
toute façon que ce serait pas forcément
parmi les premières mesures donc là il a
nommé un ministre de l'économie qui qui
ne ne va pas dans ce sens en tout cas il
s'appelle Luis Caputo c'est é un ancien
de la droite classique voilà c'est un
ancien ministre des Finances de Mauricio
MRI et aussi ancien directeur de la
Banque centrale OK et qui s'est déjà
exprimé qui s'était exprimé par le passé
contre la dolarisation et donc pour
l'instant en tout cas ça ne fait pas
partie tard oui voilà ça ne fait pas
partie des premi mesure qu'il va prendre
euh bon après le problème c'est que il
se confontent pardon vous interromp il
se confrontent au réel déjà avant même
d'avoir prêté serment est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça disons que oui enfin alors le
problème aussi c'est que c'est ce qu'il
annonce on peut pas vraiment savoir ce
qu'il va vraiment faire et ce qu'il ne
va pas faire il s'est dit d dit beaucoup
contredit tout au long de sa campagne et
donc maintenant il faut attendre en fait
vraiment le 11 décembre pour savoir
quelles seront véritablement ces
premières mesures mais en tout état de
cause la dolarisation n'en fait pas
partie pour l'instant Christophe Ventura
si on analyse un peu ce ce résultat qui
sont les électeurs de raviè May comment
il l'a emporter bah il a un socle autour
de lui on va dire et c'est déjà
absolument phénoménal d'à peu près 30 %
des argentin qui ont voté pour lui lors
des primaires du mois d'août qui sont en
fait le vrai premier tour des
présidentiels en Argentine le score a
été répliqué si je puis dire le 22
octobre au premier tour mais ce qui fait
les 56 % de Monsieur M au second tour
c'est lapport en fait de la droite
traditionnelle que vous avez mentionné
celle de l'ancien président Mauricio
Macri c'est la port et l'organisation le
parti le mouvement de la droite
Argentine qui s'est mis au service en
fait de Miley dans le seul but en gros
d'exaucer la formule bien connu dans le
monde entier de tout sauf cette fois-ci
c'était tout sauf les peronistes donc ne
surtout pas laisser la possibilité à
Sergio Massa et aux peronistes de
conserver le pouvoir donc on s'allie à
mileille donc c'est le la droite
traditionnelle Argentine et c'est aussi
ce qu'on appelle les radicaux en
Argentine qui serait en France
l'équivalent du centre droit qui sont
assez puissants assez importants dans
l'intérieur de l'Argentine et qui ont
dont les électeurs en tout cas ont
massivement voté pour may le mettant en
tête dans 21 des 24 provinces en fait du
pays et donc ces 14 millions et demi
d'Argentine et d'Argentins qu' on voté
pour M ne lui appartiennent pas en
propre il en représente une partie
importante mais il y a c'est l'alliance
avec en gros du dégagisme politique plus
de la droite traditionnelle Argentine et
et du drit qui reviennent au pouvoir
dans cette formule inédite alors en
Argentine le droit de vote il est
autorisé dès l'âge de 16 ans 30 % des
votes obtenu au premier tour par ce
candidat ravier m était venu des 16 29
ans c'est ce que nous explique cette
directrice de bureau d'étude
écoutez dans les secteurs qui compent le
plus de jeunes on observe un phénomène
de désintérêt pour la
politiqueav est entré sur la scène
politique presque comme une célébrité
avec un modèleès clair d'arrivé de
l'extérieur à l'intérieur de la
politique il n'est pas un produit de la
politique c'est un
produit Mar Rodz Blanco pourquoi le le
discours de M il a séduit notamment
beaucoup de jeunes Argentins moi
j'estime que il y a une comme comme il a
été déjà dit il y a une partie de la
société argentine en effet qui souhait
un changement voilà et qui ont cru à ce
discours antisystème à trçonneuse hein
ce discours très critique de l'État
puisque il se sentent éloigné de l'État
il sentaiit que le gouvernement
précédent n'avait pas bien fait les
choses notamment en matière économique
donc il y a une exaspération en fait qui
s'est manifestée il y a une partie quand
même des jeunes très précarisés en fait
il faut signaler qui ont appuyé
massifement mil qui les suivait sur les
réseaux sociaux et en cela ils sont été
vachement aidés par la pandémie et par
le confinement qui a été assez long en
Argentine may était très présent sur les
médias non traditionnels sur le rau sur
youtube il y a une série d'influencecur
en tout cas qui les qui les suivent et
qui euh voilà qui communiquent autour de
de la personne en fait de de milay donc
il est il est un pur produit
médiatique et cela a pu a pu
transperscer je dirais une une série une
partie en tout cas de la jeunesse de la
jeunesse Argentine vachement déçu des
institutions très éloignées des
institutions est-ce qu'on peut dire que
il y a ceux qui se sentent déclassé vous
savez le déclassement en France c'est
une thématique qui revient tout le temps
tout à fait tout à fait il y a une
partie une grosse partie du public de ce
typ Absolum les discours de Miley il il
jouent en fait sur un clivage présent
depuis très longtemps sein des classes
populaires mais accéléré ces dernières
années en fait un clivage entre une des
classes populaires intégrées et
d'ailleurs une fraction des classes
moyennes aussi assez précarisé il y a
des travailleurs pauvres en Argentine en
fait on les connaît des plus en plus
maintenant et donc il a joué sur ses
discours moralisant hein des les genses
des biens versus les voilà les personnes
qui veulent pas travailler donc Cees
discours March euh super bien auprès
d'une partie de la de la population
aussi bien des jeunes d'ailleurs qui est
des fractions adultes en fait qui fait
font partie des classes moyennes et qui
rappelons-le avaient déjà à l'époque
lors de la crise de 2001 en Argentine le
19 et le 20 décembre 2001 avait déjà eu
des manifestations plutôt conservatrices
en fait donc c'est c'est pas une
nouvelle parti la CL moyenne argentine a
toujours été invigu politiquement
parlant en fait parfois tantôt proche du
progressisme tantôt proche des positions
plus conservatrice plus de droitees H je
voudrais qu'on revenir ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le les
conditions finalement de la victoire de
r may avec donc la droite traditionnelle
qui l'a soutenu entre les de Tours en
France on parle souvent d'une digue
alors elle s'est pas mal effrité depuis
un certain nombre d'années mais est-ce
que cette digue elle
existait en Argentine ou pas où est-ce
qu'il y a déjà eu des alliances extrême
droite droite traditionnelle est-ce que
c'est nouveau bah c'est-à-dire que
l'extrême droite en Argentine est un
phénomène quand même assez nouveau euh
jusque- là il y avait cette espèce de de
de qu'on appelle la grietta la la la
fissure entre le péronisme et
l'anti-péronisme c'était ça en gros qui
a structuré la politique argentine
pendant des années maucio Magli euh donc
le président de droite qui est arrivé au
pouvoir en 2015 euh a a a a tenté de de
représenter un petit peu cette cette euh
ce candidat cet outsider euh qui n'était
ni péroniste ni antiéroniste enfin en
tout cas pas de la de l'antipperonisme
traditionnel c'est-à-dire des radicaux
et qui finalement a fait alliance avec
les radicaux a créé son propre parti est
est entré finalement dans cette cette
caste cette élite politique donc il a
été finalement perçu comme une nouvelle
forme du péronisme quoi ou une alors
nouvelle forme de
péronisme non mais en revanche il a été
perçu enfin m il a présenté aussi avant
de faire alliance avec lui comme faisant
partie de cette ce politique qu'il
consput et qu'il fallait détruire et
qu'il faut voilà détruire à la
tronçonneuse notamment et et donc le le
finalement cette cette alliance droite
extrême droite c'est vraiment nouveau
cela dit maulicio male avait déjà montré
un profil euh assez on va dire il
s'était bolsonnarisé en 2019 euh assez
proche de l'extrême droite avec un
discours euh très proche de celui de
ravier my aujourd'hui alors pour
expliquer cette victoire il faut aussi
parler de de duupéronisme justement euh
et je vous propose d'écouter la
candidate de la droite traditionnelle
s'appelle Patricia boulerrich et c'est
le jour où elle apporte son soutien euh
à Miley elle explique pourquoi
nous avons nos différences avec jaavier
c'est pourquoi nous avons participé à la
compétition nous ne les cachons pas
cependant nous sommes confrontés au
dilemme suivant opter pour le changement
et mettre fin à cette honte ou opter
pour la continuité de la mafia au
pouvoir la majorité des Argentins a
choisi le changement et nous
représentons une partie de ce
changement la mafia au pouvoir
Christophe Ventura de qui de quoi
parle-t-elle oh bah là le nom qui est
pas cité est pourtant très clair il
s'agit de l'actuelle vice-présidente
encore en exercice en Argentine qui est
Christina Kirchner bien sûr dans son
esprit à Patricia bulrich donc qui a
effectivement perdu le soir du premier
tour avec 23 % mais qui va être ministre
du gouvernement my qui va avoir le
portefeuille de la sécurité voilà et qui
fait un petit peu d'ailleurs grincer des
dents une partie de son parti au passage
enfin quoi qu'il en soit elle fait
référence à ce qu'on appelle le
kirchnerisme en Argentine alors pour les
non spécialistes du perronisme du
kirchnerisme et cetera c'est quand même
assez particulier le kirchnerisme c'est
un peu la couleur politique du
perronisme depuis le début des années
2000 depuis la crise de 2001 qui a été
évoqué lorsque l'économie s'est effondré
qui a ouvert un cycle politique nouveau
en Argentine qui a duré jusqu'en 2015 de
15 ans avec Monsieur et Madame Kirchner
qui représente grosso modo la gauche du
mouvement perroniste et c'est ce qui a
donné sa couleur de centregauche au
gouvernement qu'on dirigé 15 ans avant
de perdre contre la droite de Macri de
rediriger jusqu'à aujourd'hui et de
perdre de nouveau FA Samy avec des
accusations de corruption éayé prouvé
bien sûr oui il y a énormément de
scandales de corruption en Argentine
bien sûr ça a fait partie depuis à peu
près une dizaine d'années du l'actualité
politique permanente et cetera beaucoup
d'accusations contre justement Christin
Kirchner et cetera qui s'en défend il y
a des procès enfin il y a toute une
disons dirais une une une une actualité
de la corruption en Argentine qui bien
sûr est venu nourrir en quelque sorte
les discours antipolitiques au dans ce
large du terme de khabier Miley puisque
la thèse de Miley profondément c'est que
les problèmes des sociétés sont liés à
la corruption des classes politiques
parasites qui ne servent à rien qui sont
incapables de régler les problèmes et
qui s'en mettent plein les poches et qui
sont donc corrompus c'est la matrice qui
est née en Italie avec le mouvement des
5 étoiles d'ailleurs d'un certaine
manière il y a quelques années en
arrière et la thèse c'est que grosso
modo il s'agirait de changer la classe
politique mettre des gens de bien c'est
l'expression consacrée souvent issu du
peuple issu du peuple et puis finalement
bah comme ça les problèmes de la société
vont pouvoir disc effectivement qui vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure vertu
morale on est on est beaucoup sur des
sur ces notions là je vrais revenir sur
l'alliance avec la droite traditionnelle
Paris effectivement il y a déjà deux
ministres issus de cette droite
traditionnelle qui ont été annoncé ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il a
besoin maricelle roduez Blanco de cette
droite traditionnelle pour gouverner
pour avoir la majorité au au Parlement
c'est aussi ça ce qui se joue oui oui
tout à fait ça se joue exactement cela
c'est-à-dire que l'EN jeu là c'était non
seulement pour arriver déjà à à percer
en fait lors du ballotage il fallait
avoir le soutien de de de la de la
droite traditionnelle et c'est ce qu'il
a ritéussi voir mais s connait enfin il
connaît marcri depuis depuis un certain
temps on c'est pas nouveau en fait en
tout cas cette alliance avec la droite
faut savoir que Miley était député
depuis 2 ans et au Parlement il a
soutenu en fait en tout cas les mesures
proposé par par Mar lorsqu'il était
présent au Parlement parce qu'il paraît
qu'il était assez absent quand même au
Parlement mais voilà lorsqu était
système il va pas y participer
exactement mais en tout cas c'était
essentiel d'avoir ce soutiens de droites
pour pouvoir gagner gagner gagner au
élection et donc ce qu'il a fait dès ds
le premier jour en fait tout de suite
c'est annoncer en tout cas un certain
nombre de de personnes qui vont occuper
les euh euh voilà les les ministères les
plus les plus importants il a déjà aussi
annoncé l'occupation de ministère par
des personnes qui avaient appartenu à
des gouvernement précédent encore le
gouvernement des maccri c'est-à-dire la
période ménémiste des années 90 en
Argentine euh et par ailleurs il vient
de il y a tout un polémique en Argentine
en fait autour d'un personnage qu'il
qu'il va apparemment nommé en fait au
poste des procureur du Trésor on l'
évoqué à la fin du sujet exactement à la
fin du sujet on a retrouvé un certain
nombre d'engagement de jeunesseagement
jeun néonaz qui seraiit pro naazis en
tout cas ça a alerté fortement les
organisations de droits humains en
Argentine et puis ça ça correspond en
parti à tout le tout tout tout le cercle
en fait des personnes et ça peut tenir
cet alliage là entre la droite
traditionnelle et malgré tout une
nouvelle extrême droite en en Argentine
à l'épreuve du pouvoir voyez ce que je
veux dire oui oui ça peut tenir à
plusieurs enfin à quelques conditions
mais il y a quand même des des des
choses que Macri a montré lorsqu'il
était au gouvernement comme il était
déjà dit ici euh Macri lui-même en fait
il a en quelque sorte euh percé en fait
au niveau symbolique hein de l'espace
public il a il y a un certain nombre de
choses qu'on pe on pouvait pas dire
avant l'époque de maccri après maccri on
a pu les dire hein comme par exemple
nier les crimes commis pendant la
dernière dictature militaire entre 76 et
83 donc il a il a quand même lui-même il
était il était un peu à l'initiative des
franchis c'est pas là donc qui et puis
économiquement il faut le rappeler c'est
pas la première fois en Argentine qu'on
va appliquer des mesures des
privatisations là ça serait radicalisé
encore davantage en fait ces mesuresl
mais c'est des mesures qui ont été
appliquées dans les années 90 et puis
par mcri aussi lui-même hein alors
justement l'économie je vous propose
deux chiffres d'abord celui de
l'inflation plus 143 % en un
an ça c'est le premier chiffre qu'on
doit avir s'affiché très bien et puis
ensuite le seuil de pauvreté on a 40 %
de la population Argentine qui vit
au-dessous du seuil de pauvreté bon
voilà deux chiffres qui expliquent sans
doute en partie aussi la victoire de de
ravier my quel est le le traitement de
choc qu'il a promis pour équilibrer les
comptes est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler ça Angel Montoya bah le sa
principale mesure enfin ces deux
principales mesures on va dire c'est
réduction
budgétaire drastique donc je crois qu'il
veut que les dépenses budgétaires
représentent % du PIB ce qui est très
très bas h et ouverture de l'économie
euh donc privatisation alors
privatisation de ce qui peut encore être
privatisé parce que il y a quand même
beaucoup qui a été privatisé pendant la
période menémiste dont parlait malicel
dans les années 90 donc le peu qui reste
effectivement ils veul le privatiser euh
et ouverture c'est-à-dire ouverture aux
importation en ce moment il y a des des
politiques assez protectionnistes qui
sont mis en place qui ont été mis en
place par le gouvernement euh euh
kirchneriste successif euh et donc là ça
serait lever en fait toutes les
barrières euh pour de pour les
importations h ce qui évidemment laisse
craindre pour les PME et l'industrie
nationale mais en gros c'est les deux
les deux ces deux principales mesures et
donc cette dollarisation dont on ne sait
pas quand elle elle sera appliquée qui
veut dire lui il veut supprimer la
monnaie nationale le peso pour le
remplacer par le dollar et carrément
supprimer la banque centrale dont il
estime l'inflation économiquement
réaliste ça moi j'ai pour préparer
l'émission lu un certain nombre
d'articles il y a quand même pas mal
d'économistes qui disent c'est pas
tenable alors lui-même est économiste
heinou économiste alors c'est un ça a
été fait dans certains pays ça a été
fait au Panama ça a été fait en Équateur
au Salvador il faut avoir des réserves
en dollar c'est ça le problème c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de du fait que ça ne
va pas être fait tout de suite c'est que
pour ça il faut avoir des réserves en
dollar et en ce moment les réserves sont
négatives donc d'abord il faut obtenir
des dollars et donc toute la question
est là aussi comment est-ce qu'il va
faire est-ce qu'il va recommencé à
endetter le pays qui a été extrêmement
endetté justement sous Macri qui a pris
le la la dette euh enfin qui a obtenu un
prêt qui était le prêt le plus important
euh accordé par le FMI de toute son
histoire de 50 milliards de dollars en
2018 ou euh ou il va le l'obtenir
autrement ça euh voilà on ne sait pas
alors le le le les les dépenses
publiques évidemment c'était son son
cheval de bataille à cette tronçonneuse
qu'on a revu euh tout à l'heure je vous
propose d'écouter euh euh un extrait
d'une euh d'un meeting il était à Buenos
Aires et donc il est il est encore
candidat pas encore élu évidemment et
voilà ce qu'il
dit c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire que nous allons avoir un
président qui est un
économiste orthodoxe jusqu'au bout des
ongles et celui qui viendra dépenser je
lui couperai la
main les formules choc de ravierre my
comment peut-il concilier ces coupes
budgétaires et je rappelle le chiffre
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure 40 % de la
population argentine auudessous du seuil
de la de la pauvreté comment c'est
possible ça christopent c'est tout un
débat historique permanent j'ai envie de
dire éternel écoutez avant pour répondre
à votre question il faut préciser ce qui
a été dit c'est que les les recettes
qu'incarne Miley c'est une forme
jusqu'au boutiste de ce que l'Argentine
a déjà mis en place plusieurs fois dans
son histoire on a parlé les annes 90
qu'on abouti à l'effondrement de
l'économie en 2001 et à la suite mais
dès la dictature argentine la dictature
des vidella et cetera ils ont mis en
place les potions magiques du FMI de
l'école de ce qu'on appelle Chicago h
c'estàd on préparé la matrice quie
problème aujourd'hui vous avez une
Argentine qui s'est en fait
désindustrialisé qui a tout misé sur son
secteur du commerce extérieur basé sur
l'agroalimentaire pour en fait exporter
au maximum faire rentrer du dollar et
avec le dollar qu'on fait rentrer
pouvoir importer tout ce que le pays
consomme ça c'est le système qui a été
mis en place à coup de libéralisation de
privatisation et cetera et cetera
d'ouverture des frontières et cetera
donc ça a été mené plusieurs fois donc
il tout ça d'accord mais c'est pas donc
c'est pas un pays suradministr enfin VO
j'essaie de comprendre moi je connais
pas bien ce pays est-ce que c'est un
pays suradministré dans avec un nombre
de fonctionnaires plétorique et cetera
et un peu les de en même temps pour être
honnête c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
l'Argentine sur le plan économique la la
le logiciel et le système économique est
très libérale et s'insère complètement
dans la mondialisation économique et les
courants on va dire orthodoxe de
l'économie ça il y a pas de doute
làdessus mais c'est aussi un état avec
une administration très importante où il
y a le monde du public et le monde du
privé qui plutôt dans le monde dans
privé il y a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans l'informel et la
précarité ce qui a été dit c'est là
qu'il a recruté pas mal d'électeurs le
clivage public privé mais sur le fond en
fait il propose lui sa thèse c'est que
rien n'a marché parce qu'on a pas fait
assez dans ce sens-là c'est ça qu'
incarne my donc ce qu'il propose c'est
de de continuer à approfondir ce modèle
en Argentine alors il a mis tout le
monde à l'aise effectivement on sait pas
aujourd'hui comment il va faire pour
dollariser exactement comment il va s'y
prendre il a dit j'attends j'attends
mais il attend aussi parce que ce qu'il
a besoin de faire c'est de négocier avec
le F
F quand il all aux États-Unis première
visite c'était pour le FMI fi la deème
c'était au Trésor américain c'est c'est
comme s'il venait au ministère des finan
en France pour négocier quoi bah il va
il va négocier qu'on lui donne les coups
des franches pour les premiers mois de
son son m la dette publ pour renégocier
le remboursement mais il a mis les
Argentins à l'aise puisqu'il a dit que
le pays all allait connaître
probablement entre 18 et 24 mois de
stackflation Al pour les gens qui savent
pas ce que c'est que la stacflation
c'est l'addition de la récession
économique plus de la hausse des prix
donc tout ça ça veut dire plus de
chômage plus de précarité plus
d'inégalité pour nous promettre
peut-être que dans 18 mois 24 mois il y
aura un plan de dollarisation où bah
justement ce que vous disiez on sait pas
trop comment mais il y aura plein de
dollars en Argentine qui vont permettre
de faire cette opération tout ça semble
quand même assez hypothétique et
d'ailleurs ce sera une des tensions
qu'il aura en permanence c'est pas
forcément la position des élites
économiques argentines hein qui elles
étaient pas très très chaude en fait
pour sa victoire parce que elles ont
besoin de stabilité elles ont besoin
d'investisseurs qui viennent des
endroits où ils pensent que leurs
investissements sont sécurisés et pas
une espèce de d'alchimie un petit peu
hasardeuse qui ne nous dira rien avant
un an et demi ou 2 ans ouais alors on va
dézoomer un petit peu grâce à vous
Létitia on aurait pu croire que la la
défaite de Donald Trump signait la la
fin de la vague populiste est-ce que
cette victoire de ravier my ouvre une
deuxème vague populiste dans le monde
manifestement oui c'est ce que je
constate donc cas il est intéressant
toujours de garder un œil sur cette
Amérique latine qui a été le berceau de
quand même plusieurs populiste bien
avant les grandes démocraties
occidentales par exemple en 2015 un an
avant l'élection de Donald Trump qui lui
a ouvert en grand la boîte de Pandore au
populiste et bien écoutez le Guatemala
et lit Jimmy morales qui vient de passer
15 ans à la télévision en tant
qu'humoriste il a été acteur il a passé
toute sa campagne avec un chapeau de
cowboy sur la tête parce que il jouer le
rôle d'un cowboy qui devenait président
dans une série à succès ça vous rappelle
peut-être quelque chose oui en tout cas
il a été élu Jimmy morales avec 69 % des
voix et à l'époque il disait il
sous-entendu les autres candidats oou
l'establishment me trait de clown parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas me traiter de
voleur et c'est bien l'axe de campagne
de Morales c'était de dire regardez il y
a cette corruption rampante et je vais
moi qui viens de voilà du peuple en fait
hein qui suis des votes je vais stir le
pays de l'ornière oui donc il a il y a
effectivement un parallèle puisque milï
il a aussi promis de redresser on l'a
évoqué la situation économique de
l'Argentine alors c'est simple pour les
populistes c'est toujours le même
scénario Thomas c'est donc un homme hors
système une femme hors système qui sort
comme ça du chapeau avec la promesse
d'en finir avec un ancien système
corrompu ça c'est vraiment l'argument de
base et ça passe encore mieux comme en
Argentine quand on a un un pays qui est
miné par l'inflation et la dette
publique àysal et dans la forme ces
promesses sont faites dans un discours
qui est bien choisi hein qui ne varie
pas d'un populiste à l' c'est un
discours de vérité vous avez raison vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on est dans la
confrontation au réel et Miley a fait sa
campagne sur le même discours en disant
yeux dans les yeux hein au peuple à ses
futurs électeurs ce sera dur h et il a
même donné un délèv vous l'avez retenu
puisque c'est entre 18 et 24 mois pour
rétablir la situation et c'est une
communication politique qui séduit les
masses les populistes se présentent on
l'a dit comme des simples citoyens qui
vont essayer de sortir le pays de
l'impasse en ce confrontant au réel et
après son élection Miley a d'ailleurs
peaufiné cette stratégie et il a gagné
en popularité encore parce que moi je
pense hein il a renoncé ou il a remis à
plus tard euh juste ement cette
dolorisation de l'économie certaines
mesures qui semblaient assez radicales
le Light motif des populistes finalement
c'est la mise en scène de du principe de
réalité alors puisqu'on est dans les
comparaisons avec d'autres exemples en
Amérique latine qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire de la comparaison entre Miley et
ravierre bolsonaro au Brésil je propose
cette comparaison parce que on voit que
là la société argentine quand même
commence à manifester son
mécontentement il a pas encore vraiment
tout annoncé mais on sent que les
mesures sociales vont
être intolérables pour une grande partie
de la population argentine mais Miley a
un exemple sur le même continent
bolsonaro Thomas a gouverné le Brésil en
multipliant les sorties de route
contrôlées et mises en scène évidemment
sur les femmes sur les noirs sur les
homosexuels sur les indigène et malgré
le fiasco de sa gestion du pays pendant
le covid où il y a eu plus de 200 100000
morts donc là il y avait vraiment des
motifs de dégager bolsonaro non
bolsonaro est resté en place et c'est
vrai que depuis la France on a du mal à
comprendre qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
séisme politique donc effectivement
cette victoire de Miley montre que le
populisme n'est pas mort et l'Italie
nous avait déjà montré que l'opinion
publicque peut avoir vécu sous un régime
populiste avec le mouvement 5 étoiles
vous avez raison dès 2013 et recommencé
puisque là on a mélonie qui fait
alliance avec l'extrême droite italienne
et cette victoire de My nous montre
surtout que quand l'opinion publique n'a
pas encore testé les populistes elle
veut tenter l'expérience et peut élir un
populiste malgré les 10 ans parce que
depuis 2013 en Italie 10 ans de
contreexemples mondiaux on continue les
populistes continuent de passer au
pouvoir et on verra bien ce que ça donne
là dans la perspective mais c'est un
autre débat des élections européennes
ici en France et dans les autres pays
d'Europe deuxième vague populiste est-ce
que vous vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse ou est-ce que au contraire
maricelle rodrz Blanco c'est une espèce
de banalisation du du populisme parce
qu'on en voit partout ils s'en vont ils
reviennent il gagnent ils perdent et moi
j'ai j'ai du mal en fait avec la notion
même des populisme derrière oui voilà
c'estàd que pour moi c'est bon il y a
beaucoup de politistes beaucoup des des
collègues de voilà les sciens sociales
on parle beaucoup des des populismes
mais au fond j'estime c'est c'est un
concept qui qui ne permet pas de saisir
la spécificité du phénomène en fait pour
le dire clairement je trouve que
derrière la figure d'un populistes
derrière c'est des éléments en commun
qui existent déjà vous avez raison de de
les signaler contre le système en place
contre les élites la crise économique
les aspects rétorique des des du
personnage il y a quand même par exemple
des éléments liés aux institutions liés
à la relation avec un électorat qui est
pas homogène en fait il y a pas un
peuple versus un leader en fait il y a
pas il y a pas ça il y a un électorat
d'ailleurs qui est assez hétérogène et
qui des des des des différences en fait
entre de milieux sociaux qui ont qui ont
soutenu la figure des de May et qui par
contre permet d'expliquer mieux de mon
point de vue pourquoi my arrive à faire
ses scores et pourquoi my il est là
pourquoi il est il est président
président actuellement plutôt que la la
notion des populisme et puis il faut
regarder aussi les champ politiques tout
entier c'est-à-dire le lien avec ce
qu'on ce qu'on a un peu évoqué hein le
lien avec d'autres partis notamment
l'Union civique radicale qui enfin qui
fait partie de la droite mais il faut
signaler que c'est c'était un vieux
parti de l'Argentine qui a gouverné
l'Argentine qui est un système
bipartidiste traditionnellement c'était
un C partisan a gouverné l'Argentine
pour un certain temps et puis a disparu
les années 2000 on connu une crise mais
sans précédent descès de ces partiesl
mais qui a resté encré quand même voilà
et qui maintenant sallie à la droite qui
voilà voit dans ces figures de Javier
may une une possibilité en fait d'aller
au bout d'un projet qui était déjà en
parti mis en place en Argentine un
personnage dont on n'a pas encore parlé
et je voudrais peut-être vous entendre
angéine Montoya sur sur sur cette sœur
cadette de du du président élu elle
s'appelle Karina my c'est ça quel rôle
elle a joué et quel rôle va-t-elle je
crois qu'il la surnomme le chef le
chefcul tout à fait alors c'est un
personnage assez difficile à cerner
parce que on en sait on en connaît que
ce qu'on en voit ce qu'on en enfin ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit disons publiquement
mais c'est quelqu'un qui ne s'exprime
pas qui ne donne pas d'entretien euh qui
ne on sait très peu de choses sur elle
finalement à part que donc c'est la sœur
la sœur cadette de de jaavier My qu' ils
ont une relation très fusionnelle euh au
sein ils ont grandi au sein d'une
famille violente enfin un père violent
et et une mère que lui estime estime
complice euh et euh et donc il il se
elle lui d'ailleurs ne parle plus ne
parle plus à ses parents euh et elle est
elle la joue effectivement visiblement
un rôle absolument essentiel et c'est
elle qui apparemment prend beaucoup de
décisions dans dans la vie et dans la
dans la dans les dans les mesures
politiques et de de fravi M c'estd
qu'elle aura elle aura un titre officiel
dans son équipe sans doute à la
présidence c'est ce qu'on peut imaginer
oui oui elle doit être secrétaire
général non de la présidence ça pas
encore été officiel
officiellement officialisé mais oui oui
bien sûr elle sera très certain au côté
de son frère puisque il est parti aux
États-Unis avec elle il fait absolument
tout avec elle tout tous ces meetings
sont sont son ont été fait avec elle ça
son discours de victoire c'est lui qui
l'a c'est elle qui l'a présenté en
disant le président élu ravi m c'est
telle qu'il introduit sur scène donc
effectivement elle joue un rôle central
mais on n'en connaît encore pas
grandchose avec une part de mystère on
va parler des des droits humains et
notamment des droits des femmes tout de
suite avec Tam tranui qui peut nous
rejoindre sur euh sur ce
plateau bonsoir Tam puisque le le
nouveau président élu veut défaire un
certain nombre de droits des femmes en
en Argentine c'était l'une de ces
thématiques de campagne et oui le
programme du candidat my proposait
notamment je le cite d'éliminer le
caractère obligatoire du programme
d'éducation sexuelle il l'a qualifié
dans sa campagne d'endoctrinement de
l'idéologie du genre je précise qu'une
enquête de 2020 a montré que 80 % des
enfants et des adolescents argentins
ayant signalé des abus sexuels l'ont
fait après un cours d'éducation sexuelle
euh ravier may également toujours dans
son programme prop aussi de protéger
l'enfant depuis la conception et
l'adulte jusqu'à sa mort naturelle avec
bien sûr une remise en cause de l'IVG
qu'il a qualifié pendant sa campagne
d'assassinat aggravé par ascendant euh
l'Argentine c'est l'un des rares pays
d'Amérique latine à avoir légalisé
l'avortement c'est très récent ça date
de décembre 2020 à l'issue d'un long au
combat c'est un sujet qui a fracturé
l'opinion publique et c'est une loi qui
a placé finalement le pays à
l'avant-garde des droits sociétaux dans
la région et donc ce que l'on voit c'est
qu'avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de ravier
my tout pourrait donc être stoppé net il
a notamment déclaré qu'il organiserait
un référendum et qu'en cas de victoire
du nom il supprimerait purement et
simplement la loi il y a eu d'ailleurs
des associations féministes qui ont
manifesté à l'annonce de son élection
pour dire leur inquiétude oui notamment
le 25 novembre dernier voyez ces images
he c'était la journée internation contre
les violences faites aux femmes on voit
des milliers de personnes qui ont
manifesté à buenoser sur les images on
voit notamment et bien vous les voyez
brandy ces foulards verts qui sont les
symboles de la lutte pour la
légalisation de l'avortement parmi les
manifestantes il y avait notamment
l'ancienne candidate de la gauche
radicale à la présidentielle Myriam
Bregman on
l'écoute je pense que cette mobilisation
est très importante comme première
réponse à quelques jours de la prise de
pouvoir du nouveau président pour
montrer que les femmes seront encore une
fois à l'avantgarde de la lutte contre
toute attaque à l'encontre de n'importe
quel droit des femmes qui ont ce jour de
lutte contre les féminicides avait sans
doute en tête aussi les déclarations du
nouveau président pour qui la violence
n'a pas de genre cette inquiétude est
fondé d'autant plus que ravier Miley a
annoncé vouloir supprimer le ministère
des femmes oui c'est l'une des vidéos
virales de cette campagne on en a vu
tout à l'heure un extrait dans le
reportage de Flora sauvage on y voit le
candidat May qui propose la suppression
de nombreux ministères parmi lesquels
effectivement ce ministère des femmes
regardez miniso depte
afuera Ministerio de Cultura afuera
Ministerio de ambiente desarro
sostenible afuera ministerio dejes
género
diversiduera ministerio deras
pblicuera voilà vidéo s'intègre dans
campagne où en AZ parléavier M a promis
le massacre à la tronçonneuse des
dépenses publiques et donc un homme
coutumier des provocations dans les
images dans les mots pour conclure les
femmes ne sont pas les seules à craindre
de faire les frais des futures réformes
sociétales de ravier my la communauté
LGBT aussi est très inquiète alors que
la future ministre des Affaires
étrangères Diana Mondino a comparé
l'homosexualité au choix d'avoir des pou
merci beaucoup Tam Tran pour toutes ces
informations maricelle Rodriguez Blanco
sur sur le le droit à l'avortement donc
c'est une victoire récente ce que Tam
vient de nous nous expliquer euh euh
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer un
référendum c'est ça qu'est-ce qu'on sait
de l'opinion publique Argentine sur
cette question aujourd'hui s'il y avait
un référendum demain l'opinion publique
elle est elle est divisée comme il a
étit bien bien indiqué il faut savoir
que cette lutte là le la lutte pour la
légalisation de l'avortement c'est une
lutte qui s'est inscrite dans une série
de luttes plus historiques hein en
Argentine chez je dirais initié par des
groupes des femmes et par des groupes
féministes aussi mais depuis les années
60 les années 70 et à l'époque les
droits à l'abortement a été aussi
inscrit en fait comme étant un droit
humain en tout cas défendu justement
comme un droit la santé des femmes
justement comme bon l'un des ces faits
en fait escomtés de ces de cette
légalisation là a été la diminution du
taux de des féminicides enfin des morts
des femmes et des féminicides par
ailleurs et la la l'idée en fait
derrière en tout cas c'est à l'époque de
cette légalisation du droit a
provoqué division dans l'opinion
publique a produit la l'entation des des
des refusfin des rechets des cette
légalisation et une série des mouvements
des mouvements Provis en fait qui qui
ont qui ont grandi à l'époque en
Argentine qui se sont beaucoup développé
et et parallèlement des mouvements pour
la légalisation de l'avortement donc la
la société argentine elle est elle est
divisée elle tous les partis politiques
d'ailleurs sont divisés en la matière
cette division existait au sein du du
peronisme mais aussi aussi au sein de
des la des droites euh existe au sein
des classes populaires aussi bien Queau
sein des classes moyennes donc il est
probable que si jamais il y a un
référendum à à ces sujetsl l'opinion
publique soit soit partagée euh là on a
vu déjà qu'il y a des manifestations non
seulement des féministes mais également
de des organisations de des mères et des
grand-mères de la place aimée enfin en
tout cas initié par les les les
organisations des des droits humains en
Argentine euh et qui lutte pour le les
même raison donc il y a une société qui
est très mobilisée aussi bien de de
enfin
du côté conservateur que du côté
progressiste mobilisé autour de de ces
questions qui ont vraiment fracturé la
la société à l'époque il va rester
combien de de de ministères Christophe
Ventura je crois voilà il a parlé de h
il a l'économie les infrastructure
Affaires étrangères intérieur sécurité
et puis les trois autres je sais plus je
m noté capital humain is c'est ça et
puis justice et défenseou voilà h
ministères régaliens c'est ce qu'il a
annoncé effectivement qui sont
aujourd'hui pour ceux qu'on
connaît ceux qui sont nommés dans ces
ministères c'est plutôt les gens qui
viennent de l'ancien l'ancienne
présidence de Mauricio Macri donc de la
droitead voà mais pour l'instant voilà
on attend encore la fin des nominations
il y aura h ministère dans ce
gouvernement alors quand on sait on en
est à 40 nous c'est ça en France on se
demande comment comment on va faire pour
administrer l'Argentine avec seulement 8
ministères ou alors peut-être que c'est
la bonne potion je ne sais pas vousvez
peut qu'il reviendra sur ses annonces
oui peut-être qu'au fur et à mesure il y
aura aut ministèr qui seront recréé vous
parliez des de la Place de Mai des
maires de la de la Place de Mai qui
effectivement se rassemble je crois que
c'est tous les jeudis c'est ça c'est ça
pour pour faire le le tour de la place
dans le sens inverse des aiguilles du
monde pour voilà symboliser un un retour
dans le dans le temps dénoncer
l'impunité des des militaires
responsables des des massacres de la
dictature c'est intéressant parce que
elle s'oppose au au candidats enfin
maintenant président élu ravier mille
parce que voilà ce qu'il avait dit quand
il était candidat pendant les années 70
il y a eu une guerre et pendant cette
guerre les forces de l'État ont commis
des excès une des mères de ma lui répond
écoutez nous sommes venus à cause du
négationisme du futur gouvernement que
nous allons avoir nous voulons rappeler
et défendre la mémoire de nos 300
disparus
Bienaimé parce qu'ils disent qu'il n en
a pas eu qu'il n'y en a pas eu tant que
ça que peu importe qu'il y en ait eu 5
ou 10000 que c'est la même
chose il y a eu un génocide ici ce
n'était pas une guerre notre peuple
n'est pas parti en voyage comme ils
disent c'était un
génocide la la fin de la dictature
c'était il y a 40 ans angéine Montoya
l'Argentine elle est assez souvent citée
en exemple pour sa son travail de de
mémoire sa politique mémorielle il y a
il y a malgré tout un courant
négationniste dans le pays ça représente
quelque chose ce que ravier may
finalement dit c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à
ce que il apparaisse et qu'il dise ce
qu'il a dit il y avait un certain
consensus
même au sein de la droite de ne pas
vraiment
euh nier l'existence du terrorisme
d'État donc qui est le le fait de dire
que le le l'État a commis des actes des
crimes contre l'humanité et que c'était
un plan systématique et non pas
simplement des actes isolés de mouton
noir au sein de de l'armée oui il dit il
dit il y a eu des excès VO alors ce
terme là excès c'était la dernière fois
que ça a été prononcé vraiment comme ça
c'était par les militaires c'était à
l'époque de la dictature pour justifier
les disparitions dont on commençait à
parler de plus en plus donc il reprend
en fait le discours de de la dictature
et ça c'est la première fois que c'est
prononcé aussi clairement h donc cette
rupture du consensus elle est vraiment
historique euh ça fait 40 ans qu'on
entendait pas ce discours il y a eu
effectivement comme le soulignait
malissel en changement avec maulli qui
parlait de du du cours de de la de
l'arnaque des droits humains en disant
que parce que les il y a eu des des des
indemnisations qui ont é payé au au euh
au aux familles de de disparu et cetera
et lui a dit que c'était euh enfin il a
commencé à dire que il y avait un
business là-dedans et que donc il y a eu
quelques petites comme ça incursions
voilà le consensus se fissurait disons
mais ça n'avait jamais été dit aussi
clairement et c'est ça qui inquiète
terriblement les organisations de
défense des droits humains un mot
là-dessus pour conclure il nous reste 30
secondes oui c'est c'est tout à fait
cela ça a été une fracture une fracture
symbolique je j'entends dans l'espace
public de pouvoir énoncer cela comme
cela alors qu'on s'apprêtait à fêter à
fêter les 40 ans de la démocratie de la
la continuité institutionnelle en
Argentine et c'est et c'est ça qui est
un donc ça ve dire ça n'est pas un
repoussoir pour les électeurs argentins
qu'un candidat ose dire ça pour une
bonne partie de la population argentine
en tout cas non c'est-à-dire que ils
l'ont voté mais sans sans connaître
véritablement le fond de de ses de ses
de son programme en fait et des
propositions qu'il fait et les fonds du
personnage non plus ce qui interroge
aussi sur le rapport entre cet électorat
et les votes mais vous avez souligné que
les électeurs votent à partir de 16 ans
la plupart enfin les électeurs de 16 ans
et même leurs parents n'ont pas connu la
dictature donc la question de la
transmission de la mémoire merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat les je vais rappeler le titre de
votre livre la tentation du clown aus
éditions bchet Chastel demain dans la
matinade noter que l'invité Doriane
montsini sera l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle benoî amamont qui est
aujourd'hui directeur général de l'ONG
Singa merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité à
[Musique]
demain